[Music]
how's it going bros man it's peter pack
today we're checking out one of my
favorite subreddits of all time
curse comments it's just a wonderful
distraction
from the fact that we're all gonna die i
don't know why i started it like that
i like it okay that's what i'm trying to
say oh my god i didn't know you could i
googled cursed comments and i see myself
oh my god i didn't know you could hang
them
logan paul in japanese forest be like
good one
there's another pewdiepie wait this is
i don't get it i don't get it no not
november let's go let's go bros come on
what are you [ __ ] simp yeah this is
always a trip because they're so edgy
and i never know like
where to draw the line clearly but let's
see let's see if we can try and not get
cancelled today
i am not a burger you're more than a
burger you're a steak you're a stew
a versatile queen is what you are uh
cows can't speak this is just cringe
i don't get it just realized that king
kong was a legendary
simp for sacrificing himself to a woman
he can't even have sex with
yeah everyone's busy canceling everyone
no one's canceled king kong for being
consent he could have sex with her but
she
would not be wait what
not really apes have much smaller penis
approach than a human
the average hp is about what
70 completely survivable it's completely
it's completely survivable the size of
that pp
it's completely survivable it's it's
definitely
imagine you miss a payment on tesla and
it drives itself
back to the dealership that'd be kind of
sick imagine dead
old people in their teslas just arriving
places
oh
i need another one quick people who had
sex with celebrities how was it
great until they kicked me out of the
wax museum
you wake up in the air 30 20 after being
cryogenically
preserved what is the first thing you do
boot up a porn simulation let it rip
out a thousand years of built-ups
why why is that what you think you have
what the man no not november let's go
show you can do a month let's go come on
bros i don't speak japanese but i'd say
she enjoyed that she repeatedly says
you've been visited by good sleep
hamster upload within this next six
seconds and you'll be blessed
with cozy and restful sleep oh i want
this i upload to view more in such
cute photos of hamsters visit x hamster
no not that i know but no again
no not november bros let's get it what
did we learn
that your cat can make your death seem
like a suit
no no oh
oh oh this subreddit i need protection i
need protection
guys come here you too maya maya
oh she's dreaming maya oh this is
perfect
okay now i have protection if anyone
reposts out of context
at least i will be with cute pugs and
people won't hate me
right guys this is great i want i won't
excuse squeeze you maya maya please
don't i'm not squeezing you
uh oh god it's jack oh no breathing
normally
is easy mode i turn on the asthma
difficulty for the extra challenge
it's a fun joke jack is a funny guy uh
all right let's see how people respond
oh so it's an optional difficulty how do
i turn it up
start a new game no
oh look pugs have breathing problems oh
look they're not laughing oh god i'm
getting double canceled
no oh what was that maya you want to say
something
oh she's uncomfortable she's angry sorry
maya sorry queen
there you go look her nails aren't even
long now look at that
how about that i found my ex-girlfriend
body in the morgue i work at it was very
awkward
still giving you this
the cult stop
what is the last one what is the last
one did she oh
okay all right good that's pretty funny
actually
the licking part was so realistic until
i figured out my earbuds fell out and my
uncle was licking my
ears nah biogradable cigarette filters
with flower seeds
help nature in two ways by planting
trees and killing you
[Music]
oh god we crashed the site guys we did
it
you guys always look like you're
completely drugged out let's say it's
cause i feed
them and they bit and walk them and then
after that they're just like
all right we're chill now what is it
maya
oh god she's gonna she's gonna fart
she's gonna fart guys
we did it i forgot to mention this this
is very important we hit
107 million subscribers
this is huge coco melon got no chance
but more importantly you think you're
tough
cocoa melon tambourine tower to the moon
[Music]
yeah [ __ ] you hey puggis come back
hey hey hey hey come here hi youtube
maya oh she's being a real debbie downer
look at her maya
all right just look cute that's all i
need you to do this picture speaks a
thousand words
why i'm so confused she got filled with
that optimus slime
yeah there uh yeah i don't like when
they're all sexual
nice work agent 47 now make your way to
extraction point
i don't get it and i'm glad i don't get
it because that means
i am wholesome and i this is probably
something dark
all right and i don't i'm too wholesome
yes i'm wholesome
uh what's the best response to are you
sexually active at your doctor's
appointment with your parents not that
i'm aware
that's good curse barbie okay can you
spot the problem
dinner ain't getting ready yet you think
that's a curse barbie
i'll show you a cursed barbie martial
made this look edgar's so scared of it
okay why you don't like it you don't
like it again
he's so scared of him why don't you like
him
oh sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry that's
sorry put it away don't worry
don't worry i'm sorry if you
feed a moose it may become aggressive
and attack the next human it means if it
has no
food to offer what the [ __ ] feeding
emerge is my favorite hobby now
yeah just always make sure you have food
for the moose
everyone knows this come on oh he's
sleeping
my apple broke the apple cutter and now
i have a weapon
jesus keeps the doctors away
no i think that keeps the doctors to you
if you try and eat that one mcdonald's
start using fresh beef today so what the
hell were we eating before
well every once in a while a kid gets
lost in the bone pit
all right let us never forget the time
the world's smartest man made a dick
joke
i can finally get an erection the
doctors disabled my pop-up
blocker stand up
colony
oh this hurts i'm a as a fan of stephen
hawking this
i'm sorry ghost of hawkins he wouldn't
like that joke i
i'm sure of it i'm sure of it i lost my
parents
i lost my son oh sweet he also lost his
wife so ben
bent down bet no no no if you stop these
halfway through sometimes they're just
wholesome
still not over the fact that when i got
my prosthetic legs they were like do you
want to be taller and i was like
yeah and then they made me two inches
taller wish you were me
time to cut up it's that simple
everyone that ever got big pee pee boat
uh you'll you'll get a letter
in the mail talking you through the
procedure it's uh
it's it's safe hundred percent of the
time that it works
schlatt the view from my window today is
freaking crazy
why is the sky red your window hella
dirty the neighbors did a gen
good joke yeah made me laugh
[Laughter]
kenyan official homosexual alliance
learned it from
copying gay tourists personally i say
hats off to the gay tourists who are
willing to be
in front of lions
hey gay people that takes balls man
that's how you know they were gay
you need twice as much i know ag jokes
are sometimes too far
but it's taking dark things and making
it turning it around himself
at least that's what i think and i
understand everyone is different but
come let us enjoy it please
complete the sentence wait don't jump
it's not that high
get to them
i'm ending i meant no no can we end with
a hold someone please
edgar you're not helping you're not
helping help me what's the weirdest
place you had sex
our parents bed are oh god
no edgar apologize all right i apologize
for this video once again i'm sorry
it wasn't my fault hey edgar you want to
hurt him you can hurt him
oh dude that's sexual sexual joke stop
it god why did
what is wrong with my wife why did she
do this are you still scared of him in a
girl
you still scared
let's start to be afraid of
he just wants to pet you at the game
i'm sorry i protect you i protect you
all right thanks for watching guys leave
a like if you enjoyed and as always
subscribe
we're trying to be coco melanie's
subscribers so i really appreciate it if
you hit that subscribe button
it's free you don't have to do anything
and that's it see you tomorrow audible
[Music]